this is actually a really big story that
broke out this week so USA Today is no
longer going to use the official White
House photographer pictures of the
president and of the first family
because they feel that this is basically
propaganda but coming from the White
House 38 news outlets agree with them
and they sent a letter to the White
House protesting they're shutting out of
independent photo journalists in favor
of taxpayer-funded photographers the
White House official photographers named
Peter sauza so what you're seeing on the
left there that was just taken by any
old photographer and this is obviously
in washington DC at the mall and all the
photographers if you look at the picture
on the right they're all stuck in there
in that spot and they're getting that
sort of distant picture but the official
White House photographer he gets a
pretty sweet spot right behind the
president the full image and everything
else right there that's Peter salsa on
the left with his camera and that's a
that's a image from a regular
photographer who has to get him in the
picture to get the good picture of Obama
and then obviously on the right that's
the good picture of Obama and that's the
picture that then gets tweeted out by
the White House and then picked up by
all the news organizations and all that
now this one is particularly interesting
so this is the Obamas visited the cell
where Nelson Mandela was held this was
they announced that this was going to be
totally private that they were going to
be no photographs taken at all however
yes photographs were taken of course
this is done by Pete and the USA Today
their director of multimedia he issued a
statement on this the functions of the
president at the White House are
fundamentally public in nature and
should be documented for the public by
independent news organizations not
solely by the White House press office
and that's Andrew Scott from the USA
Today so I think what's interesting
about this is this has always been done
we can think of pictures of every
president in modern times where they
have the official White House picture
but what's different here is that now
because of social media once it gets
tweeted out by the official account
everybody picks it up no man
different though because the White House
this White House is barring so they're
all photographers from going in on the
Nelson Mandela visit reporters were
barred from going in they were not
allowed they were told no pictures only
to find out on Twitter a little bit
later that there were official pictures
you know who else does this Iran and
North Korea stay on me do their absolute
value I am saying about Russia here yeah
that's what they do I mean this is
outrageous but you know what if the
reporters in the White House press corps
are not going to be up in arms about it
they all want to be like sheep and
follow it you know they're looking
ridiculous but they are starting to wake
up right yeah okay here's the thing I I
think there is an issue of propaganda
and I part of my brain Toli alliance
with that but then there's another part
of my brain maybe it's the vein side
that feels like doesn't the president
and his family have a right to control
their media image in that way like if I
see a picture that I don't like of
myself on facebook i'm gonna untag it
seriously it kind of the same appointed
by elected i was gonna say I know it
won't happen here oh but no and get that
so the fact that he's our president
makes it different but I understand some
desire even if it's not necessarily from
bad motives I guess is all I'm saying it
might not be but it's because I know
what everyone think it was untagging
himself on facebook that's it's another
to bar everybody with a camera like you
guys think there's a distinction between
the public events so let's say that
event at the mall at the MLK thing or
versus where where there can be a lot of
photographers there and they penned them
they literally put them in a pen vs uh
something private in the White House I
can understand that if he's on a phone
call uh you know with rouhani that that
can be the the official White House
because you can't bring in a zillion
photographers all that they lie I live
this problem for eight years and that
reporters are never going to be happy
until they are actually inside the room
where the decision is being made the
problem is they're not saying anything
to this White House they've spent five
years allowing this White House are now
a little bit it's a little late we've
been we've been through the reelection
uh you know my problem is is that you
don't get to uh say that you're for
journalism and then stay quiet on this
because your room your room
winning journalism so I think the
hypocrisy is really taken America back
in terms of freedom of the press yeah
why do you think it's a slippery slope
I'll say that kind of contradict my
previous statement in that if it gets to
this point where there is such
restriction and banning and and I have
sole control over my media image then it
does create a lot of space for for bad
things and stuff like that does this
also go to how we were too focused on
image constantly because this White
House obviously in the advent of social
media everything is very image focused
and it when I was reading the story was
reminding me of Marco Rubio in the water
bottle whatever his rebuttal was that
night nobody even remembers but everyone
remembers this guy uncomfortably having
dry mouth and grabbing a bottle of water
and that's what was I mean CNN literally
ran a headline did this destroy his
career right so is there something about
image that maybe we're getting
completely out of control with instead
of substance yeah I mean yeah yeah
obviously yeah I mean that's the thing
and that's um I think we got to decide
where we want to place that moving
forward this is not new we've seen this
gradually happening for years now and I
just think because of social media it's
just now at an all-time high and we are
we're visually stimulated and engaging
and it's been something that the Obama
administration has benefited from
greatly but you know I did it's not just
going to always be the Obama
administration in the White House um so
we have to think about where that's
going to lead people moving to I don't
I'm not surprised that politicians are
trying to control their image or are
worried about you know what the public
thinks of them that's absolutely normal
I think it's organic I also think that
the Obama team is not totally to blame
for wanting to control that and taking
taking it to the next level from what
the Bush administration did the next
administration is going to be even worse
however with that being said they're
absolutely needs to be a check and a
balance from the media from the White
House press corps to say no and what
they did is for five years they allowed
this creep and I mean the creeping of
the
process J Gordon no no I mean this slow
creep yeah of of having their rights
completely taken away from them now they
are concerned now they are saying things
like wait a minute you're doing
interviews with you know celebrity-type
magazines and not sit downs with real
journalists and and they've made this
bed and they've ruined the journalistic
process in while doing it right that's a
slight off topic but i really like that
so is there anything they can do to
change that because even now when i
watch presidential press conferences you
know he's got three people that he asks
questions too many answers questions for
so long that they never ask more
questions because nobody even knows what
how it started but also they purposely
set it up so that he asks questions of
people that aren't gonna add and ask
important questions and follow ups and
things like that is there anything we
can do at this point are we sorted down
that rabbit hole now infantile too far
yeah I mean I do I like the checks and
balances thing I think ideally here's
what would work best but it might be too
late you can have your own designated
official stuff that you have control
over and you present yourself and your
family the way you want to and also have
independent objective journalists do
their job so that America feels like
there's a there's some diversity there
but I agree maybe it's too late for that
now so in terms of the photos couldn't
you have the official White House
photographer just with everyone and it's
still an official white house photo what
was happening in the bush administration
look I i think that the daily White
House briefings and the the press
conference is from President United
States you're not going to get real
information there that's all for show
and it's gotten worse and it's and it's
never going to be the situation where
we're going to get real information
journalists need to do their job they
need to investigate they need to go to
the different cabinet officials they
need to dig down so that we can get the
truth yeah I don't expect the President
United States to know every detail of
what's going on so at a press conference
I want him or her to give me the the
kind of overall strategy I'll get the
details from someone else